france del reino unido están uniendo
esfuerzos políticos y diplomáticos para
convencer a eeuu que extienda más allá
del 31 de agosto su presencia militar en
afganistán para permitir que la
evacuación humanitaria de más ciudadanos
de afganistán pueda continuar la idea es
que mantenga su gran presencia militar
en el aeropuerto de kabul el ministro de
defensa británico dijo que eeuu tiene en
este momento seis mil personas en
terreno afgano que una vez tengan que
salir de ese país también tendrá que
hacerlo del reino unido- y dijo además
que uno o dos días harían en realidad la
diferencia en este proceso de evacuación
humanitaria este es uno de los grandes
objetivos de la cumbre virtual de los
líderes del g-7 que se reunirán mañana
reitero de manera virtual para tomar
medidas concretas de espera para que
esta crisis humanitaria en afganistán no
siga creciendo para esa prórroga más
allá del 31 de agosto sea una realidad
el talibán tiene que aceptarla un vocero
del talibán dijo en una entrevista con
sky news que esa es una línea roja y que
si las tropas se mantienen en terreno
entonces habría consecuencias